if you own a pc you've probably hit
these three keys a million times control
alt delete almost instantly unresponsive
windows computers let you kill specific
apps that could be causing a problem
then there's command option escape if
you're a mac loyalist and there's
control x control p control c what have
you have you ever wondered why you have
to perform awkward finger gymnastics to
get it to work rather than just hitting
one key i sure have and who came up with
these seemingly random key combos anyway
i asked around and found out they're not
as random as you think i spoke with
apple microsoft and ibm and the
information i gathered led me to one guy
david bradley a retired pc engineer
he didn't invent keyboard shortcuts cut
copy and paste were dreamed up in the
1970s at xerox he did however come up
with one of the most well-known
three-finger combos while working at ibm
control alt delete it took david about
five minutes to come up with a shortcut
and back then it really wasn't a big
deal it was just part of the job
we didn't spend much more time thinking
about choosing those keys than i've
spent explaining it to you but it turned
out control alt delete became a major
and lasting contribution to the world of
personal computing after the shortcut
caught on in ibm's pc lab it spread to
other internal teams and eventually made
it onto the original ibm pc from 1981
that bulky grayish box and keyboard
introduced personal computers and three
finger shortcuts to the masses so what
about all those other keystroke
combinations the origin stories are
usually the same
shortcuts either start with a problem
that needs to be solved or a function
that needs to be more quickly accessible
typically someone or a group of people
comes up with a way of doing it without
triggering other functions and then
those solutions make their way onto
keyboards and computer programs that we
all use microsoft told me that in some
cases some shortcuts that are rarely
used evolve over time to become
something that people can use more
seamlessly in the beginning one person
might have come up with a new keystroke
however nowadays it can take a whole
team of designers hardware and software
engineers and program managers to come
up with one new command companies want
to adopt new ones that are collectively
easy to remember and make sense with
existing keyboard layouts i learned that
they make keystrokes easier to perform
if they think it'll be used more often
so zooming in and out of a page
shouldn't require much finger
maneuvering however launching command
centers might also most people don't
want a keyboard with a thousand buttons
you rarely use so keystrokes allow you
to make use of what you already have the
proof that they work is that we have
computers nowadays with touch screens
and mice and track pads even voice yet
we can still use the shortcuts like
control alt delete every day
if you're feeling really creative mac
and windows computers let you create
your own shortcuts but before you do
that hit this little button to see more
videos like this i'd also love to know
what you want to know more about so let
me know in the comments and i might just
answer it in my next video
you